you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and going to play a 300 game all
right let's be quick you don't have
increments
now alrighty let's go for this idea of
getting your bishop your LightSquared
Bishop exchange for their light square
bishop here we go
Bishop e2 or Bishop to d3 on 8th ok
there which makes c4 not a possibility
now ok
isn't that a blunder some opening trap
Bishop takes pawn King f1 no I'm earning
a lot of time Bishop takes King Bishop
takes King f1 how am i rescuing my dark
square bishop hmm I don't know
I felt pretty uncomfortable taking that
let's take care and
get developed really soon they're gonna
gain some time against my clean where
should she go when attacked maybe home
she too good for her home oh sorry about
that one bad joke all right well we're
even up on the time here which is nice
and I like seeing that move whoo
let's go here développé I was thinking
about Knight f5 yeah
ara mm let's do this I think Knight f5
g4 and I have to under develop and I
don't think I have the time to be under
developing so I'm bb5 night here and
Bishop e3 Queen c7 I'm fine with that
this is a long-term target so castles
rook c8 it's the big bad plan also Queen
c7 strikes at this point there is no h4
maybe there is because in the end I'd
have enough protected piece on h4 but I
don't see any double attacking type
moves maybe they're lining that up I
guess they're going to go with h4 and
should insert h6 not so fast
don't be so quick to give ground like
that let's throw a punch at e5 let's see
how they react to that that'll show them
hey also you could think about h5
yourself although that pawn is a bit mmm
tough bit tough
hmm well yeah I definitely don't want to
play h5 now it's Queen takes and I don't
want my dark squares broken down with
this hey you can't have it all remember
that you just can't have it all oh the
clock man the clock all right let's do
this
get ready to go to the night corner so
no I know it's the square you dreamed of
right from the start and now you're
there dreams have come true buddy all
right well at least I didn't weaken my
dark squares but my knight he's not
gonna be too happy with me yeah he's not
too happy how do you rescue him to play
up six well let's get the Queen's off
yeah it's not gonna go down to position
look at the clocks it's just a mouse
race let's go a pun do some damage okay
in-betweener
yeah let's do it
hit him with the in-betweener there we
go Knight c4 still a lot of pieces
around my king
scary Queen trait they shouldn't go for
that that was a very bad move but I just
did that was very bad Queen here I want
to get really how my night is brought to
life he loves it he loves it
um Queen here another Queen trade Queen
f7 oh my goodness do that um yeah I have
a draw really my Kings gonna get wild I
think this is okay the Queen gets
trapped Queen's trapped oh she's not
does that move oh boy
hmm wow it's getting crazy this is no
good oh boy in very big trouble had a
run
Oh oh my god yeah oh man that was very
risky to decline a repetition and run
like wild towards itself it's Mikey oh
that's what you risk when you you risk
losing you risk losing Lee oh man that
was bad that was bad my goodness
yikes yikes how can I have better
handled these three Oh games man they
feel like bullet they just especially
what doing commentary with the three Oh
games they just fly right by
Wow yeah I thought right around let's
put the analysis on right away
yeah let's investigate this what's what
this be formal yeah
takes here King there chop-chop what am
i doing about this night here rook there
where am I going here no man see that
pawn is poison how tempting it is to
take here with check right mm-hmm he
doesn't have a good way to retreat so I
ran away scared to take first here
what's the big difference
still this no way I'm not giving up a
piece hmm okay I was just for a moment
thinking oh there's compensation I get
two pawns for and they have a king still
in an awkward spot potential target no I
don't like this no no no no no no I'm
not taking an f2 but I mean the
alternative is
what it doesn't like Bishop back I mean
I know I'm under developing but I wanted
to keep this square open for my night
here it's taken mm-hmm
maybe here is fine with this still is an
idea and I know I would end up with
double isolated pawns but I do get the
bishops maybe maybe this is an idea to
develop the knight like that it would be
faster for me to develop my pieces if I
did it like that but the downside is uh
I'm conceding something on the Kings
side my structure is crushed so I felt
pretty normal right here but yeah I need
to be a bit careful of this wild age
upon how should I better approach this I
play Queen c7 Queen e2 okay yeah I mean
this was the other move I was
considering to have f8 for my knight but
this is what I feared h5 and h6 and then
these holes you know like right around
here I start to imagine you know a dark
square Bishop exchange in a queen kind
of sneaking her way into the g7 square
because of this pond on h6 you know so
instead I played h6 and hmm well in the
end what am i doing I'm thinking more of
structure then I am the health of my
knight you know is that really the
correct and mindset to have been in I
don't think so I think it's important
that I make sure my knight remains and a
far more active square like f8
and so I guess he can't have it all
you're gonna have to uh just take some
extra care of the g7 square and work
within this structure on the computer
isn't pointing out this because why and
it certainly is a move I need to be
careful no not that Queen here to here
and I have to develop my queen to the
defense of these dark squares and here's
another thing the other thing is that I
run the rest these is the other
long-term issue with allowing this pawn
on h6 if they're long term issue is that
I how do I ever get my king safe for as
long as the Queen's are on the board I'm
always having to I would always have to
be wary of back ranked mates I don't
have a good flight square there is no h7
there is no going in this direction
especially with the Queen's on the board
I really want to stay away from f6 maybe
maybe you could get that in but yeah
these are the this was the dilemma I was
in to allow the pond to get to h6 or to
you know be okay with the knight in the
corner I know
okay well this is what we had that
in-betweener right here to here but mmm
Knight to c4 yeah this is what I wanted
to do and yeah I immediately regret it
Queen to c4 because of this fantastic
reply queen g4 which may have very well
been the idea with Knight 2 h2 although
maybe this was even being lined up with
a surpise sack on h6 they have some
serious space they have a serious space
advantage on the Kings side Queen c4
Queen g4 King f8 Knight takes Wow
it does like to sacrifice the strong
Queen takes and yeah I push clean check
here we could have had a draw of I was
thinking that the Queen was going to be
trapped by grabbing this pawn and now
I'm lost
Queen takes Knight King here I should
have just taken the repetition that was
a the correct objective thing to do yeah
I mean I kind of had an eye on the clock
as well
mm-hmm I should well no I don't know
that it was so much I had an eye on the
clock in that position as much as I just
I don't want to draw you know like
clearly risk losing risked losing but
you know I thought that this was this
was working out objectively for me and I
didn't want to draw I thought that if
they pushed right and that's this is the
only move I was considering I thought
they'd go straight in for the check in
that I could go here in okay yeah now
it's winning because I could real
upon my Kings position for this moment
but they just simply run away with the
Queen so I clearly didn't put a lot of
thought into the variations at this
stage and the different move
possibilities white has on this move 31
I was just thinking oh you go straight
in for that check but in the end yeah
the Queen would be trapped but Queen is
rescued Queen h7 and I am just busted
even calling out for a mate and 7x yeah
now it's trouble when you have to play
Queen there here there's a check and
then here and it's lights out yep or
here and then here mate so yeah that
would have been really strong this move
one move later King h7 well I might have
made a King move the pawn push they did
go with that and they already have a
mate the Queen check bishop their pawn
push yeah they should have gone with
pawn push I was thinking they were gonna
do that but they didn't do it even
though they could do it even now they
could do it and when it hit well we
didn't have any time on the clock to
work it all out
mmm even ever mean I'm making two right
around here mate and two right here with
the Queen check
oh what a cool finish that would have
been right yikes
yeah but really the you know
knows how it's gonna finish when it's
those uh that rat race at the end but
the the things that I'm taking away from
this one are this interesting with beef
or how tempting it is to grab on f2 but
you're basically going to be down a
minor piece if you do that there's no
escaping there's no running away with
your Bishop once it's on f2 so that is
one thing that I found interesting and
the other was how to maybe better
prepare for this H pun that's really the
big one
because yeah it's my knight who's he
became sidelined and it was tough trying
trying to weigh these two these two
moves here SH for do you allow your
knight to go in the corner or do you to
play h5 and stop their pawn from getting
to h6 if I could do it over I mean
because even here even here the what's
the computer pointing out Queen c7 it's
going with this but I'm not a fan of
this position and I'm not a fan with how
it played out in the game with my knight
in the corner so if I'm to avoid both of
those scenarios both of those position
types I think I need to come up with
something better right now instead of
this routine castling move so let me
just give a little bit more attention to
this point right here well could I have
done better in this middle game position
okay it suggests this I guess there's
nothing wrong with that right away we
need to to defend and 85 oh okay I'm
seeing I'm seeing something with maybe
making this pawn flinch playing its pawn
up like if we have this variation again
where mine I could go here and my bishop
could go to c5 is what I thought the
idea would be
although they're still getting in that
pond to d2 a6 or h6 excuse me and hmm
this is interesting because maybe I'm
okay in this position with allowing the
pond to get to h6 because I haven't
declared my king's intentions just yet
he's not on the Kings side and when we
consider the Queen side I know I have a
upon this pretty far advanced but I kind
of feel like there's the possibility at
least for my king to be secure on the
Queen side in large part to my control
over c4 and me maybe being able to play
a Knight to c4 I'd still like to avoid
this H pawn to this H pawns advance all
the way down here don't know if I'll be
able to work this out right now I'm
recording but yeah certainly the thing
to focus in on this is what's capturing
my attention a way to to improve here
not have this pond be an issue and not
end up with a knight in the corner a bit
tricky certainly a bit tricky I guess I
know it won't really like that will it
tough move to make as well but here and
then maybe a knight reposition to f5
it's tricky
I'm not sure and I don't know again I
thought I'll be able to come up with and
the answer here I even it even pointed
out right here Queenie - maybe not
castle in this h5 idea to stop h4 maybe
that's a little bit different yeah
because what kept me what was it in the
game that kept me from playing Age 5 it
was that I saw the H pawn is vulnerable
and I was right to think that
but if I'm on castled I still have my
rook here that could defend the pawn and
because of because of that I have a
better night position who's still
struggling in a way of course he has
pressure on e5 but as far as these moves
they're ruled out boxed out nicely by
the pawn on g3 if I could get that in
maybe that's this is an approach an h4
h5 and even even now now that they have
this structure and this is what I really
would like to have happen my knight get
to the f5 square even looking at
something like this here and then Knight
to e7 so this is a way forward I guess
is the short story another another
approach to have in the back of my mind
when combating this wild H pawn yeah I
could think of and I could not be so
quick first off to castle and do these
routine like moves yeah I should have I
should have anticipated this h4 advance
right now at this moment here and had in
my mind I was going to meet h4 with
stopping him cold that's as far as he's
getting I want to play h5 and go
uncounseled which isn't so bad an idea
when we consider the center of the board
and that it's pretty much under control
but yeah just another idea to have here
this h5 advance okay well crazy end to
this one clearly but uh you know I
learned a couple things from this one
and I hope you did as well okay as usual
feel free to leave any feedback in the
comment section below and I'll catch you
in the next video that's all for now
take care
you